Disney is releasing a new Star Wars  every year Marvel and DC releases  superhero movie every few months and now  we'll be getting annual Transformers  films until at least twenty nineteen  that covers transformers five six and  seven behind the scenes Michael Bay  confirmed that he's returning for  transformers 5 we haven't heard about  directors for the other two movies but  Bay has stated that he wants to hand the  reins over to someone else meanwhile  hasbro studios president stephen jay  davis confirmed that his team of writers  has created a decade's worth of story  lines for the robots in disguise that  applies to transformers on television  and on film the first four Transformers  films have grossed almost four billion  dollars some more movies shouldn't be  that big of a surprise we'll see what  they bring to the big screen each June  over the next few years and if we learn  more about the next trio of films you'll  hear about it from gamespot